cloud functions gives developers quite
an ideal experience you write code you
give cloud functions your code and cloud
functions takes care of everything else
to run it in a fully managed production
environment ready to run thousands of
invocations of your code at any given
time one of the defining traits of
serverless platforms like cloud
functions is that you get to focus on
writing your code the platform handles
the rest serverless means that these
operations get abstracted away from the
developer experience
those abstractions can also be
constraints your code will only go as
far as those use cases that the
underlying platform can support this is
why we are introducing cloud functions
second generation a new version of cloud
functions built to bring new
functionality to the platform
this means cloud functions can now serve
even more developer use cases all while
maintaining the same developer contract
and simplicity are you concerned about
running a bit more intensive code in
cloud functions
we've bumped up the amount of resources
an instance of your code can use to 4
cpus and 16 gigabytes of ram
do you spend extra time working through
how to roll out new versions of your
code to only serve a portion of requests
or invocations
cloud functions second gen makes this
process declarative you can now just
tell cloud functions how traffic should
be split between different versions of
your code
all of this is possible because cloud
functions second generation
re-platformed its underlying
infrastructure to use google cloud's
container service cloud run
but don't worry despite this change the
experience remains the same for
developers write code deploy to cloud
functions
finally second gen will also greatly
expand the sources that can trigger your
code's execution over 90 plus event
sources are now natively supported
through event arc new sources like
bigquery for many of you this means that
you won't have to wire together custom
code to trigger their code from sources
that previously were not supported in
cloud functions whether or not you're a
cloud functions pro we encourage you to
get started by looking at our
documentation our code lab that walks
you through these new features or even
directly visiting the cloud console
which has been updated to help you
seamlessly onboard into deploying your
code to cloud functions this is
stephanie wong